in order to get governments giving large
amounts of money though we need to
demonstrate at quite a large scale
how cash contributes to ending extreme
poverty our data is very very strong
at a village level even a district level
but the impacts of doing it at a full
national scale
taking a single country and doing cash
transfers to everybody in extreme
poverty hasn't been tried yet I think
it's important it's done because
if it can be demonstrated that we can
make a significant difference the number
of people living in extreme poverty
through cash transfers then we can
change an entire International
conversation and all that 165 billion
dollars a year spent as you say innate
money by the World Bank by the UN by
different countries
I think much more of that could then be
directed towards cash but at the moment
we still live in a very old-fashioned
world where everybody was told
no don't give someone a fish teach them
to fish